so that it still the YouTube videos that
came out of the puter yes okay yeah this
is a fun way of putting it but all right
it's true yeah you'd be surprised what
you find in my puter how is how do me a
favor tell Lucy not to come over until
ten tonight okay no no no see oh you
know what rhymes with Lucy I'll see you
tonight hey when you get there make sure
he knows that he couldn't find her cuz
she's been at my house for the last
three days sorry nice i'll see you
tonight I'll see you guys tonight don't
quit messin with me I'll see you guys
tonight hey tell do me a favor tell Jim
he's not gonna she's in her his
girlfriend's not gonna make it tonight
she's been at my house for the last
three days wait I'll see you tonight I
originally started actually I started
filming a homeless guy and his name was
doing I started like monitoring his
every day everything that he did day to
day and it was really really funny he
was funny guy and so if you go all the
way back to my original videos like my
first handful of videos there meet doing
videos that's what I called him and they
were literally him singing the beatles
in the park him talking about like
everyday stuff he collected all this
stuff put it in stores you and it's just
a really crazy story that this guy had
so I'm through that and establishing
like 500 followers out of that you know
I started on uploading prank videos
after that the arrangement that we had
was like I would go out and film him and
wherever we were on location I give him
bring him stuff not bringing money bring
him food take him out to dinner stuff
like that so we he was actually turned
out to be 0 a really good friend but
through after may be uploading 10 of
those videos i developed a fart maker
that i'm sort of known for is the park
guy now it's called the puter and in the
beginning that's what i started
uploading only hooter videos and I did
it to market
product initially we started selling
maybe two or three hooters a week
something like that and you know slow
and start now and everything and then
NBC show on NBC got all of us and said
they wanted a license a clip which now
happens more frequently cuz more videos
and stuff but back then it was a huge
deal it's like oh my gosh I'm going to
be on a TV show on NBC so it was funny
cuz they called me and they said we
can't actually advertise the puter but
we can name the segment anything you
want and I knew that when you go to
google and type in the puter I'm the
only thing that came up so i said i call
it the puter so they aired it on TV
titled the puter in print and bold print
right on the bottom of the screen we
sold like 300 the first hour so we went
from two or three pooters a week to 300
the first hour that that thing haired
and so today we're consistently selling
roughly 2,500 3,000 pooters a month
there's another guy that contacted me
and actually has a contraption that
sucks I'm not making this up sucks in
your farts seals it shut and you can
just blow it out whenever you want you
literally have a fart at your fingertips
in this little balloon device and you
could just that's it there's something
about capturing the fart and waiting
hours later to release it that makes it
more rank it's a little foul usually I
have a pretty good pretty good feel for
for the environment and you know if it
looks like there's anybody recognizing
me I'll address that first you know and
kind of walk around a little bit and say
hey how's it going and you know and
everything
it I'm still I think i'm so pretty safe
my mom was married to a while when I was
young to a man who was just the ultimate
prankster he would fart in public
legitimately and laugh about it he would
get this weird look on his face and he
would fart he would crack the loudest
one off and I was just a kid so it was
still embarrassing but funny at the same
time so he that's just the way that this
guy was and I think that that really
kind of followed me and so I've always
kind of been a prankster and now I get
to do it every day so he really impacted
me who's like my dad I think my personal
favorite prank is probably I think
paranoid is probably my favorite thing I
always had the intent with paranoid to
make sure that the person that I was
describing had no idea what I was up to
in the world you know so i would just
dress like a normal guy who am I talking
to why am I describing them picking out
strawberries and putting stuff back on
the it's just weird you know my my my
number one favorite guy that I work with
right now is Tom mabe mabe in America
before YouTube I bought tom eames prank
call CDs and he was like I'm legitimate
let's just listen to this girl oh yeah
tickets no no hey hey tone it down just
a little bit hey no that doesn't sound
like it to me you know what I mean every
day every night yeah good day every
night that's good only on the weekends
and that's it never yeah what's in the
house song itself she's referring to the
vibe in the Bible the book so I think
it's Berg chapter 7 37 like thy breasts
are like clusters of grapes and that's
in the Word of God I'll show you mine
let'em ones I got bigger wish that
they're not on the outside looking for
your brother man given that a day
already have a lot what Minister David I
was worried about the way they might
have been big where Kazon darlin oh that
proud mary keeps on burnin rollin turns
bible scripture of the day you ready are
you ready bible scripture of the day I
got one already raised a god here we go
you ready no one whose testicles are
crushed will enter the Assembly of the
Lord Oh a mess now that stimulation haha
look it up karmically it up look at me
are in the Armageddon it cuz we're
Armageddon it this is he well Armageddon
goes well imma get in a minute can I
finish my there real quick and then do
an interview with you you got it yeah
thank you very much you god bless you
I'll never ever do a mean-spirited prank
I just did a prank the other day that
went up and did really well it's called
a Vaseline high five in the beginning it
was a little bit controversial just as i
knew i was gonna get some a little bit
of hate for it i'll look some people are
gonna die that's mean you know it's bad
but it wasn't me i think
fine and it turned out funny you can
always get Vaseline off it's just a pain
in the butt I just like to confuse
people can I show you something yeah Hey
Oh police came the police officer who
showed up heard what on their way to the
store they knew what happens a guy's
fart maker you know it upset this other
guy and he went got up he started
hitting this younger guy so they knew
this story so they knew it was me the
officer who showed up first knew that it
was me and he goes up he walks up to me
and he was so so don't tell me what
happened Jack so you already knew my
name before I said it and so I started
showing us you know I figured they told
him my name I started using the puter he
goes I've seen it before may have seen
all your videos so it's good to have
cops that are your friends and your fans
would have most people I think sort of
defended me because it was so ridiculous
to overreact on something like that but
also he was defending his wife because
he felt like I farted in her face so I
guess you know that's okay guy farts
near your wife in public piece of crap
Adam I don't I don't do anything that
deserves to be arrested so if i did get
arrested um i'd probably go out and do
the same kind of unless i made a stupid
decision hmm you know i didn't cross the
line I've never been a couple of those
moments I was out with some friends of
mine recently and we were doing the kid
c bitsy spider prank and there's some
officers standing right over here and
four of them in a row and spider came
down to one of their faces and oh man
got a great reaction it's online and it
was great three the officers thought it
was hysterical one of them's like hey
I'm sure we could pick you up on
something you might not want to do that
again
just attitude you know
business for several years selling movie
and TV memorabilia online so that's
that's how I supported my family for a
while it was you know what kind of rough
and I know I'll tell you I never thought
that I'd be supporting my five kids and
a wife farting in public it's ridiculous
that could even be someone's career it's
an actual option now I mean that's crazy
you know because ten years ago it
couldn't be there's what are you gonna
do you know put up a web site start
making videos and you got to find your
people find fans you get a fine and it
was just different back then today it's
an actual possibility to do skits our
pranks or seeing covers of songs or play
the guitar or whatever and actually have
a career doing stuff it's amazing
through my youtube videos Dick Clark
Productions hired me for the nude
bloopers TV show and so we just shot 40
episodes of that and half the season was
filmed here right right Huntington you
know near my house so which is really
really cool and then you know there's a
lot of other things that happen TV
companies will approach you all the time
to license little clips for their shows
or whatnot so it kind of transition from
a youtube career into a TV career and
back and forth so now I'm kind of
branched out a little bit more I think
it depends on a lot of things the same
hat in the same way as like having a TV
career or movie career or something like
that or an author right I think you can
make certain choices that all kind of
make you go downhill and spiral downward
and then I think you can make good
choices I prayerfully consider
everything that I do in my career so
that I make good choices and you know
hopefully that will continue to grow my
my fan
get people to tell their friends and you
know subscribe now have you ever been
arrested yourself I've been yeah for
what he had actually no 36 sorry 36 is
kind of alive 18 I'd kind of go with you
but like 36 is you have not a look my
name up bro I got 36 cases what do you
get arrested somebody use such a nice
guy man every time I see it I know a
good guy oh is that a couple times 36
times sounds like if it ever happened i
think i might continue my your
merrymaking ways what's that your
merrymaking ways what woody me like
you'd continue with your pranks you
would you wouldn't give up pranks all
together if you got arrested how like
you like say say you did something that
did get you arrested oh let's say the
where do your phone paranoid person
routine the where you call it in you you
talk about somebody that you're in front
of in line let's say they talking about
you'll be on the phone and you'll kind
of say oh yea though he's kind of
standing out in front of the theater
here alright he just looked at me okay
now if you were doing something like
that yeah and it wound up getting
arrested I guess we were we were capping
off that you want off what is it like
stopping it like putting an exclamation
point on that idea that you wouldn't
stop doing your humor okay so
what's up I just messing with you so
time ago funny guy I'm ginger and I'm
just like I started to feel really bad i
guess poor guy keeps having to explain
himself